listen if you want to grow your youtube
channel faster and your overall business
and brand online you got to work on your
personal brand if you look at the rock
elon musk you look at those that are
leading a business but also have a
strong personal brand anything they do
they get more attention they get more
impact and then they also ultimately can
drive more revenue so i'm excited today
because our guest on the growth video
live show is anthony o'neil he's a
number one national best-selling author
he's helped over 250 000 people set out
on a path toward a debt-free life with
his chart-topping book debt-free degree
and he is crushing it on multiple
platforms he's got a hugely influential
show called the table and his awesome
youtube channel and he's going to be
sharing with us three secrets really for
how we can strengthen and build our
personal brands so we ultimately cannot
just experience more success on social
media and youtube but make a greater
difference in the lives of people all
that and more is coming up today on the
grow with video live show
[Music]
welcome back to the growth video live
show my name is sean cannell rhymes with
youtube channel and i'm super fired up
for uh anthony o'neil on the show today
anthony welcome how you doing man sean
man i'm doing great thanks so much for
having me on the show today man
man i appreciate you so much we're gonna
get straight into these tips but if
people are just meeting you can you give
a little uh vision about who you are and
uh what has brought you up to this point
of 370 000 youtube subscribers impacting
people with this powerful personal brand
that you built what's your story in a
nutshell man in a nutshell my name is
anthony o'neill um speaker author and
just a guy who's passionate to help
people get out of debt build wealth and
just really maximize you know the season
that they're in you know 18 years old uh
made made a lot of bad decisions while i
was in college and while i was in
college when i wrapped up about 35 000
worth of debt
parents were upset made a bad decision
in college kicked out of college uh lost
my job lost my income and because of
that you know i lost everything right
and so when i lost everything i thought
i was going home and my parents like no
since you've made these decisions ao you
are going to live with them and so i was
homeless for six months of my life and
during that season of my life you know i
realized that there were a lot of things
that i wanted i wasn't taught about
money
and so i said hey when i get out of this
season i'm going to learn everything i'm
going to consume everything i read books
from your robert kiyosakis from my
mentor and friend dave ramsey a total
money makeover took his course i'm
studying because i wanted to travel
around the world and teach people how to
get out of debt how to start the
foundation of building true wealth and
really how to just really maximize you
know the season of your millennial
season and so i'm passionate about that
i talk about that on my youtube channel
my podcast and just excited to be
connected to you and just learning a lot
man
man so grateful to have you on the show
just respect your work and especially
how you're helping people uh with their
finances and reaching financial freedom
but then also just the behind the scenes
of how have you built your brand up and
i'm excited because you have a couple
tips today that we'll kind of go through
in this conversation and uh by the way
if you're just joining the growth video
live show smash the like button let me
know where you're watching from and
let's kick it off anthony with tip
number one which you say
build a vision that is bigger than you
when it comes to building your personal
brand you actually want to have a vision
bigger than you what do you mean by that
yo when i when i say that is uh sean i
want people to think about hey what's
bigger than me how can i
uh help people how can i serve people it
can't just be hey i want to go out here
and start a youtube channel or start a
podcast channel so i can get a bunch of
brand deals and so i can make a lot of
money no why do you want to do that what
why
um do you want to go after this
particular vision right and i say this
and your why should be so deep that if
your why doesn't make you cry then the
price of commitment to accomplish your
vision will make you cry okay and so i
tell everyone like hey i ask yourself
this question what is your vision and
why is that vision and then when you
identify the why you should get
emotional you know my why sean is i grew
up watching uh my my mom have the
struggle of you know because i love you
baby i'ma stay with you and my mom had
to work three jobs they had arguments
over money uh we were living paycheck to
paycheck and so my vision was i want to
help other people not be in debt not go
through struggle of i want to help other
people have wealth so they can raise
their kids in a wealthy environment in a
peaceful environment in a joyful
environment not in a struggled
environment not in a paycheck to
paycheck environment and when i think
about that of what i'm going to provide
to my my next kids you know i get a
little emotional i won't do that today
because i i want to keep going but
that's that's what i mean it can't just
be about you but it has to be bigger
than you
it has to be bigger so you can really
make a big impact your why should make
you cry if you're watching the show let
me know your why in the comments section
what is your vision for wanting to build
your personal brand your youtube channel
uh anthony how has that evolved for you
um you know at one point you had zero
subscribers you know at one point you
had zero influence uh and and now today
you're at another you're at like a
mountain top as we reach levels in
business and impact and then you see
that there's even further to go
how did you develop and cultivate your
vision for those that are maybe lacking
vision
um they know they want to be doing this
but things are a little confusing and
cloudy how do you recommend kind of
getting clarity
when it comes to clarity i would suggest
sit down right sit down and really cut
off the phone get off of social media
um you know tell your boyfriend tell
your girlfriend i'll call you later um
and just really
sit back and just sit
and just ask yourself okay what am i
good at
what what can i do in my sleep like what
what am i very much so passionate about
once you write that down i want you to
write it down then what i want you to do
is go to three people that are close to
you whether this is maybe your pastor
maybe this is whether this is your
parents maybe this could be a friend or
somebody and ask them hey what do you
see in me like and give them the
opportunity to be honest and then write
all that stuff down
and then when you go back home see what
a lies what did you have written down
and then what did they have written down
and see what a lies and if something
doesn't align then the next part is i
would go to like an accountability
partner or mentor or or a coach uh for
me it was a spiritual i have a spiritual
advisor um like my pastor and i said hey
this is what i'm thinking this is what
i'm sensing these are what the people
who are close to me are saying this is
the vision i'm thinking about going down
what's your thoughts and that business
coach or that that spiritual coach or
whatever coaches in your life right now
they can really help you fine tune
exactly what is the clear vision because
we all because we're internal sean uh
sometimes we need somebody else to see
something in us that can help us really
get that vision really fine tuned
and sometimes i think we try to do it on
our own rather than allowing someone
else to kind of challenge us and poke
holes into things and pull out even more
wow that really sounds like clarity in
community that you don't want to be
just developing your vision just by
yourself it's powerful to get alone even
get into prayer even really get in front
of a journal but then also to refine
that with other people i absolutely love
that and uh man you're already dropping
so much fire hit like you've been
getting value but we got to go to tip
number two which is on when it comes to
building our personal brand
impact builds influence and that
produces
income breakdown that process for us
what i what i see
typical influencers or and brand people
like us right we tend to focus on the
income right we tend to focus on okay
how much money can i make how much money
can i save or how much does this cost
and i'll be honest when i first started
off in this in this whole influencer
space
i would say i was asking myself the same
thing okay how much money can i make how
much how much how much how much how much
and then i really i'll be honest and
frank when i got around you know my
friend and mentor dave ramsey um and was
serving at a local church in
jacksonville florida i started noticing
that you know dave will always say if we
help
our people
we are rewarded
by with green
and when i started hearing them say if
we just help if we just serve then we
are rewarded by green and that is
currency that is dollar and i was like
okay
so i started teaching myself and telling
myself anthony the income's coming but
first we got to be focused on making
something and generating something that
is impactful and then what is impactful
now becomes influential and what's
influential now brings you in more
people because they're being impacted
and your reward is now income and so i
focus on now every show that i produce
every speaking engagement that i i go on
every time i get a brand off deal offer
i've said no
to more brands than i've said yes to why
because you have to help me impact my
tribe's life if your product if your
service services cannot help me impact
my tribe i don't want you uh just just
last week i turned down a brand deal
that was offering me 50 grand
over a period of two months and i was
like can't do it i mean this this is not
really helping it's not impacting and i
want everyone who comes across my brand
to be impacted because i want to be
influential there's two types of of
influencers right the first con is an
influencer that is impactful that is
getting income then the next one is an
influencer that's just getting income
they're not impactful that influence is
not going to last long because your
content
will will produce uh change in people's
lives change then produces currency oh i
just made that up oh my goodness i
literally just made that up when you
change someone's life you know that will
produce currency but it starts with your
content oh my god let me let me write
that down i literally just get up we got
it on the replay so we'll be able to you
know turn it into a tweet in a graphic
and then uh spin that off into your next
show such powerful principles
um about just leading with value first i
mean uh it's just it's inspiring and and
i love this so impact builds influence
that produces income yeah so so who are
you impacting you know we talk about
think media uh really the the the law of
money one of the money laws is your
income will be directly correlated to
the amount of value that you bring to
the marketplace
if you can lead with value first if you
can give significant value we also just
hope to uh deliver more value than we we
receive that's what whether goods and
services whether i buy your book whether
i ultimately want to support you through
a membership community that people can
do on youtube and as creators through
patreon or channel memberships you know
or whether i want to get hard goods or
services anything we ever do transacting
for money is we just believe where we're
giving money in exchange for some type
of value and if we can give
massive value and what's powerful as
personal brands right if we can give a
lot of free value it builds trust it can
build life change and and then it can
lead ultimately to income it sounds like
you're saying that income becomes the
of ultimately impacting people and that
we are best positioned to create a real
legacy if we don't pursue money as the
first thing would you say there's some i
think people have money mindsets right
and you're you're an expert at this
sometimes it's like we go to extremes
you're saying if money is the only thing
we're pursuing we're not going to last
but what about those that are also they
they actually let let off the gas too
much much maybe they have some money
mindsets i'm kind of afraid to make
money or i'm afraid to charge what i'm
worth or i'm afraid to sell something or
what if there's some negativity if i put
something out there can you speak to
some money mindsets that you see
yeah one of those is that you know sean
it's it's the you know hey um i'm not
going to chase money but then i don't
want to hurt people's pocket i i don't i
don't want to charge too much and i
agree you shouldn't charge what you're
not what you're not worth and really i
don't think none of us are really
charging what we're worth i know sean
doesn't i've i've purchased some of his
courses and i'm like man this was worth
way more
than what i actually paid for um and
that's good but at the same time you
want to be a good steward over your
gifts and your talents and you have
those gifts gifts and talents so that
you can provide for your home and so
don't go into the mindset of saying hey
i don't want to charge this price
because i don't want to hurt their
pocket well no you need to charge a fair
and reasonable rate for your services
for your gifts and your talents there is
something on the inside of you that i
need that shawn needs that this world
needs or that our community needs and so
don't have the mindset of oh my goodness
i don't want to pay this much um another
mindset that i have that i've seen is uh
shawn that i think hurts a lot of
people's pocket they become a jack of
all trades and it's like they want it
they want to help everybody i want to
help this person that person this person
that person and i don't i don't think
that you'll be able to scale long term
so one of the things that i focus on i
want to serve everyone but i have a
target so like my target when it comes
to me is i really want to help the
minority community get out of debt and
start building wealth i'm not saying i
don't want to serve anyone else but i
make sure that as i'm building content
i'm making sure that i am touching a
specific demographic so that way and
targeting them so that way i can impact
them but here's here's the thing though
shawn when we did our study while i am
doing that i've noticed that i'm still
very
broad within my particular
demographics i have caucasians i have
minorities i have i mean i'm i'm very
wide and and it's shocking
because what i've learned is when you
when you talk about money
you really learn that everyone learns
something
but i've learned reason why i've been
able to grow as fast is because i spent
time saying you know what i see a void
i see something that's missing in this
particular community or in this
particular area let me go fill that void
and then i'm making sure that i'm not
excluding anyone from the conversation
and i think if you really want to grow
your brand if you really want to be
impactful find a void uh identify your
target people and serve them well and
those people will love you and be okay
with not being accepted by everybody and
i think that's a key thing to have
wow you know that reminds me of a quote
from zig ziglar that says don't become a
wandering generality
be a meaningful specific and on the
topic of personal branding i love
anthony that she just broke down that
it's it's powerful to have a focus it's
sometimes people are afraid of the word
niche or niche because it can feel
limiting
but in a world with so many distractions
with so many different channels with so
many different people to follow by
narrowing down your focus you ultimately
are able to stand out and not only that
it's kind of like it speaks to what you
just taught on an impact yeah you know
the shotgun versus the laser if you have
a shotgun approach you can do you can
have a wide spread but it's not going to
go very far where the laser can go for
miles and miles and miles and miles but
it's a it's a focused beam and so uh
super powerful i'm excited to get to
your third tip in just a second but as a
reminder y'all
anthony is one of our speakers at grow
with video live 2022 and uh
during the grow with video live show um
you can get
uh five percent off tickets still now
we're about 90 full and so you're gonna
want to grab a ticket the week the event
is uh a week out uh virtual we don't
have a cap but in person
unfortunately also i guess fortunately
it's already gonna be lit it's gonna be
crazy uh and so we are gonna sell out so
you're gonna wanna make sure if you're
on the fence and you wanna come to las
vegas and hear from anthony o'neil gary
vaynerchuk patrickbetdavid make sure to
grab a ticket grow at videolive.com use
promo code
gwvl show for five percent off and uh
check out this quick video if you're
just hearing about grow with video live
this thing is your gateway to get out of
the thing that you complain about but
people would rather complain about how
it is than put in the work we need to
start understanding how big this
opportunity is because for everybody in
this room you will sit back in 20 30
years and regret if you didn't execute
in this era it has never been a better
time in the human race ever to actually
just go all in on you
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time to beat
you
this is the greatest golden era of not
only business but life
i desperately want you to win
but this is on you
[Music]
may 23rd and 24th las vegas anthony
o'neill's one of our speakers anthony
we'll get to tip number three in just a
second but gary said a statement at the
end of that video and and gary is known
for for being really bold speaking in
extremes but he literally said like
this is the greatest
era
for betting on you like this is the
greatest era in human history no less
did he say you know um but but you've
been kind of living in this and
experiencing that i wonder what what you
think about that i know for me youtube
online video i'm a small town kid
college dropout um didn't have any
connections in hollywood or media or
anything and and for making videos in my
bedroom we were able to build a company
and we have 25 team members and it's
just crazy um as we go into this next
decade though like what do you feel
about the opportunity of this space and
and from your perspective your
experience the people you get to impact
what do you think about when you think
about you know building a brand and even
a business online
sean i i would say this it was the best
decision i've
i've ever made
a lot of people i remember growing up i
thought youtubers
was not a career
i thought it was not it wasn't a
reputable you know job
um but now when i see the opportunities
um that his it has afforded me oh sean i
mean listen i get to wake up
go downstairs into my basement
and and and work and do what i love to
do and make a lot of money doing it and
i would before we went on live i told
you i was like man this is awesome you
know i
i'm experiencing things i'm like wow god
this is this this is i could do this um
and i think the best thing for me is
it's not just paying for my life i'm
able i'm not as big as you um as of yet
but you know i have three full-time
employees i'm supporting three families
and i could do it comfortably while
impacting
people's lives and so i think now was
the best time if you all are watching
this and shawn didn't ask me do this but
i'm gonna tell you all right now get to
the conference if you haven't registered
to the conference and you need to plug
in uh with everything that sean and his
team is teaching
because i'll tell you this much about a
month ago i sat down with him and within
a matter of 30 days implementing what
i've learned from him and what i'm going
to learn in las vegas after i get done
teaching we doubled my income on google
adsense and so
now was a great time to get online with
youtube with your podcast because you
can generate you can and you will
generate a six plus to seven eight
figure business simply about just doing
what's on the inside of you and
impacting people's lives
so powerful and i want to get to tip
number three but you got me inspired
when you said you know i get up and i
just go downstairs and i want you to
explain a little bit about this awesome
studio that you have i pulled up a video
here just tell us a little bit about the
studio that you built and the situation
you've set up to work from home yeah
yeah yeah so you know i um um i was in
the market of looking for a home and so
i just moved to the dmv area right and
so i was looking at stuff i was like all
right should i just go buy a town home
or or and go buy another building and i
was like so i did the math and so my
accountant was like no how about you go
get a bigger home and we'll be able to
write off some of the square footage
like in your basement and so i have a uh
a full studio down here and we came down
here and we built a full-blown studio
i'm looking at my teleprompter right now
or where you all are um it's with the 6k
blackmagic on there i have about four
cameras in here see if i can pull down
the mic i don't know if y'all can see my
mic but my mic is above me i got lights
and then y'all can see um i have you
know my earpiece in and so where i could
do i could do interviews like this i do
a lot when it comes to news interviews
and i have a you know a great a great
opportunity here man and i said hey
i want to be wise with the opportunity
um and i want to save money so now i
don't have a large overhead when it
comes to rent i was able to just get it
within side of my mortgage and so as i
scale i may have to change but as of
right now i mean i literally wake up
brush my teeth take a shower eat
breakfast brush my teeth again and then
i meet my team downstairs and we get to
work and we literally
um have to use your format and it's so
simple we record one week out of the
month then my team edits
and then we post our videos and so we're
working real hard for one week out of
the month and then two weeks out of the
month we're strategizing what's next
what are we going to put into place who
are we going to interview and here's a
here's a good thing about being your own
your own employer or your own employee
right is we actually take off a full
week of the month because i i want to
build a culture and environment to where
it's like hey we're not working as hard
i want you to spend time with your
family but when we are working we're
focused we're dedicated and we've been
able to generate you know some good
revenue you know we're doing very very
well and i'm excited about this
opportunity
man so inspiring to to see the studio
how many square feet is your studio or
yeah where you are right now so the
whole thing we have a waiting area
outside right so we if we look at the
studio plus the waiting area where
there's a bar outside where people can
come and sit down with their weight and
come in we're looking at about right at
900 square feet um then the other part
of the basement i have a a little gym
down there for me and my staff we work
out throughout that week and then i have
a little small little movie theater over
there so this the studio and the waiting
area which is all separate has his own
entrance is right at about 900 square
feet
man i love it well hey that was an
awesome breakdown we got tip number
three coming up but smash like have you
been getting value and maybe tag
somebody or share this uh conversation
an interview with somebody that
you think this would inspire or some
tips they'd find valuable as well
but tip number three here for really
growing your youtube channel faster your
online presence faster by strengthening
and building your personal brand is to
be willing to live in your uncomfortable
zone anthony break that down
yeah you know there's this quote that
says nothing extraordinary happens
within your comfort zone
um and
and it really it it makes a lot of sense
um and i think a lot of us the reason
why a lot of us don't scale is because
we live
inside of the comfort zone
um you know true story i'll make it real
quick um it's a little weird story but
but follow me here my teacher bought a
frog she gave us a frog she said hey
we're not we're not going to dissect the
frog we're going to boil the frog so we
gradually just boiled the frog right
from 1 to 10 slowly
frog was jumping around went to sleep
and unfortunately we boiled the frog um
i raised my hand and asked the teacher
this simple question i said hey what
happened because how come the frog
didn't fight for his life and she said
one good thing
she said frogs get comfortable
in the heat
and then as i was growing up something
hit me and said that the frog didn't die
in his sleep it died in his comfort zone
and i think a lot of us really have to
understand
that the things that are comfortable may
not always be the best thing for us and
when i stepped out on my own on my own
it was very uncomfortable when i hired
my first person full time leaving their
job to come work with me it was
uncomfortable uh when i just hired
another person it was uncomfortable when
i'm cutting these checks it was
uncomfortable but i've learned being
uncomfortable has made room for me to
impact more lives now we go back to
point number two when we impact more
lives we're we're becoming influential
when we're becoming influential now
we're producing income but sometimes
we're not willing to step out we're not
willing to go to uh sean and say hey
sean just just gut check me rip my
youtube channel apart tell me what is
wrong tell me what i need to do wrong
because it's uncomfortable to hear what
we're not strong at it's uncomfortable
to have a coach to have an
accountability person in your life to
gut check you and say hey listen you
gotta do this better you need to do this
better and i believe if you really want
to scale if you really want to grow your
business if you really want to grow your
youtube channel then you need to get
with someone that's not going to tell
you hey that's a good job only hey this
is good but here are the areas that you
need to gut check yourself on hey you
need to hire these people i know it's
comfortable seeing your account over
here but if you want your account to go
up you need to make these higher so
that's going to you know spend more
money
and you'll be all right but don't allow
your comfort zone to become your kill
zone
powerful word someone said that was deep
and actually if you've got a question i
think we have time for one or two
questions post four question marks
before and after the question so we can
see it be willing to live in your
uncomfortable zone i want to thank louis
for the super chat i decided to get out
of my comfort zone thank you for sharing
that louis and that is where the magic
happens and you know what's interesting
anthony is it it really doesn't get it
doesn't get easier you don't just take
one step outside of your comfort zone um
you have to keep taking steps out of
your comfort zone you know our first
event uh grow with video live this is
grow a video live uh five in our first
event um years ago we were in way over
our head we it ended up costing us a
hundred thousand dollars at the red rock
uh resort here in las vegas and we um we
lost twenty thousand dollars now kind of
typical sometimes running an event
overall business was healthy because we
we knew we could recover from that um as
well as there was the brand lift and a
lot of other things that happened
there's a huge stretch for us some of
the things i learned though is it didn't
kill us we were able to learn from it
dial down you know continue to move
forward but now we're stepping into
2022 we're going to the m hotel right
now our p l statement which we are
hustling to stay up with we're our cost
on this event is somewhere around uh
eight hundred thousand dollars so far
and uh we're we're on our way and and i
we could be somewhere near a million
dollars
um and it's just crazy five years later
and so i could look back and saying this
in all humility i look back and maybe
run in a hundred thousand dollar event
and and i wouldn't even break a sweat
but right now i'm sweating a little bit
yeah
like we're we're it was just new levels
and so i've just kind of learned is that
man there's for progress i think just in
life in general if you want to have
another level in marriage you still you
got to get uncomfortable maybe be
another level of vulnerability if you
want to have another level in business
you got to get uncomfortable and so just
i would like to say it gets easier maybe
it's kind of like a muscle you develop
but every time you come up
against a bigger giant a bigger goliath
you got to tap back into you know power
from god and some faith to say man i
gotta i i the lion and the bear the
hundred thousand muslims were able to do
that but i mean
i think we could take down goliath i
hope though like jonathan and his armor
bearer yeah like i don't know maybe the
lord will be with us come on let's go up
against you know let's see if we can do
this thing and that's kind of where we
are right now so i love that you shared
this be willing to live outside of your
uncomfortable zone what was one of the
early moves you made
you just made a big one you stepped out
you're cutting your first checks three
people
upgrading your studio investing money go
back though what was an early for for
those listening
one of those things that or any any
anywhere on the journey but one of those
times when you had to really you know
punch fear in the face and get out of
your comfortable zone oh man you know i
think one that's very real and trans and
was trans uh
it's it's it was an emotional one right
it was it was honestly right before so a
lot of people who know me know me from
dave ramsey but a lot of people who
found me through dave ramsey didn't
really realize where i was before and so
i was
um connected to a very big church
in jacksonville florida about 30 000
members right sean and all of them
clearly looked like me and i remember
being the youth pastor there on the
teaching team teaching every sunday i
mean the jaguars knew who i was the
principals the the mayor i mean they
were all calling me like i was
comfortable i was i was living a good
life and then i just felt
this desire that hey i need to serve you
know all people and i need to really not
just serve people who look like me but i
need to you know get out there and serve
people who do not look like me
and then i got the call from from dave
and his team to come and serve with them
and man
that
i was like i was willing to
you know
go over
but i didn't know i was gonna go from
literally all black to all white and i
and that's two different cultures
nothing wrong i love white people i got
white people on my team but it was two
totally different cultures and i was
scared i was like what what like dave
and their culture is amazing but i've
never been a part of a company that has
a spelling bee competition that has the
battle of the bands and i'm like this is
cool this is not this is not me right
and i was like man but you know what
i think
i i had to do that because if i would
not check this out you guys y'all see
this this this plaque behind me you see
this book behind me um i wouldn't be a
number one wall street journal national
bestselling author i would not have
impacted over two or three hundred
thousand lives i would not have been
able to talk to 12 million people every
single day i would not have been able to
been on the stages that i've been
blessed to be on if it was not for me
stepping outside leaving my comfort zone
and going to work with an amazing man an
amazing team and being willing to be
uncomfortable
i wrote a book that sold over a hundred
plus thousand copies i've i've been able
to be in success magazine i've been able
to do a lot of different things because
i was willing
to be uncomfortable and i learned a lot
i made a lot of mistakes sean during
those seven years i learned a lot but
you know what
because of the years before that in the
last seven years now you know i am able
to impact people and i think a lot of
people don't really understand that hey
yeah it looks like you're winning
but really you're losing because you're
not willing to be uncomfortable and to
hear you talking about man 800 000
that's scary i couldn't even think about
that right now in my particular season
but i know it's coming and here's here's
why i will be willing to step outside of
my uncomfort zone because when that
season comes who's the first person i'm
gonna call sean hey sean i'm gonna do
this i'm scared i'm nervous can you give
me some wisdom i got you and watch this
sean can give me the wisdom he'll calm
my fear but i'm still going to be a
little uncomfortable but at least i have
wise counsel
guiding me and directing me on the
journey and that's what i recommend when
you step outside of your own comfort
zone do not step out by yourself when
you start a business do not start it by
yourself get wisdom get counsel get
accountability people around you that
can guide you along this journey they
won't make it easy but they will make it
easier
strong let's do a lightning round of
questions here 40 to happy says um
anthony how can i build my brand and
it's but it's catered to a specific age
group and then also specifically women
and eventually i want to have courses
any advice for this question i mean i
say start it you know i mean i would do
the research make sure that that
particular age group and that particular
and woman specifically want it now let
me say this much
um when it comes to the youtube world
and pretty much buying market they're
golden
brothers we have a hard time spending
money but ladies golden when it comes to
spending money now the age group i would
make sure that that age group that
demographic that you're going after
they they need what you have to offer i
think sometimes we get it confused we
think that we're going to force what we
want onto them but we got to make sure
that we do the research see is there a
void will they like this and if they if
there is a void then we feel it but we
can't force people to like what we like
so you know i really don't do age groups
um but again i think if you are if you
feel called and you feel like hey i'm
i'm supposed to talk to 20 something
year olds
just know that every single year you're
going to be going after a new market a
new group of people because every year
that age is tracking so i would say
maybe maybe just figure out an age um
bracket rather than a specific age
um a specific age
strong this is a good question from
danny and uh danny's asking finding and
trusting counselors or you know you said
get wise counselor or get coaching get
people around you you mentioned you
you're able to talk to your pastor yeah
um but what's the best way to identify a
coach or a counselor and and i know that
it's a big question because sometimes
even someone hears somebody throw out
the word mentor and they're like where
did i get a mentor sean's got a mentor
and sometimes i use that word because it
is it's i have mentors in the books that
i read and the podcast that i listen to
but then also certainly in more formal
situations so this this question comes
up a lot anthony for those that maybe
feel isolated and alone and are looking
for that kind of maybe you could break
down the term but it's like coach mentor
uh you know guide uh i've you mentioned
you had spiritual guidance you know from
your pastor and it's kind of a big
category that could be overwhelming when
someone just says okay i want to get
help but where do i start
well let me tell you the first place to
start exactly what sean said books
podcasts youtubes i think a lot of
people get confused that you have to
have someone uh physically uh talking to
you here's the truth i've known sean
before shawn knew me you know i've i've
been following sean for like four years
my first camera
was bought because sean told me via his
youtube channel to buy this camera and
as he was growing as he was elevating
his cameras i was like yo i need to do
the same thing and so i would encourage
you to lock in go and do research you
know if you want to be a speaker okay
you need to be following john maxwell if
you want to you know if you want to get
into the money space you need to go sign
up for dave ramsey's uh financial
coaching series like if find the person
that is doing what you want to do
one follow them two when they offer like
an event or a call yo you need to be in
the room i'm not saying need to be in
the very front seat i'm saying you need
to get into the room get around other
people who are after the same thing as
you and then what's going to naturally
happen watch this because now
you're consuming their content you're
going to their events you're getting
plugged into their world naturally
you're going to find a mentor if it's
not that specific person you will find
someone who can give you what you need
but the problem that i see with people
is when you don't if you get a mentor
you have to then from there you got to
trust them you got to be vulnerable you
got to be honest and you got to give
them the room and the space to
respectfully correct you if you do not
give them that room if you do not give
them that space then you're not going to
be successful in your mentors i i have
two ears
two eyes and one mouth for a reason
and when i got on the phone with sean
and he was going through my youtube
channel and he said some things like hey
this is not as good this needs to be
better do this just be better i just
said yeah yeah okay okay okay and i was
asking questions but i was listening
more and because of that you will see an
improvement so i would encourage you all
and i read i saw a comment earlier on my
computer saying man it's hard to find a
mentor
it's not really hard if you're open to
the fact of you could be mentored
through a podcast youtube and books um
now if you're saying i want someone
physically talking to me
then yeah that could be a little hard
but you got to start in this area
i want to get to a couple more questions
but anthony for those who want to learn
more from you um
tell us a little bit about your show the
table and how people can connect with
you man you can go to anthony.com such a
good question right there um and you can
go to youtube look up anthony o'neill on
youtube look up anthony o'neil on
podcast it's called the table um and we
are just really having a real relevant
and relatable conversation with
everything around money around uh
getting out of debt around building
wealth then also really too uh we're
starting to get into this whole thing
what are some good channels um and how
can you start building more wealth and
so i would encourage you to go over
there we're having some real good
conversations it's it's pretty um you
know it's pretty spicy uh we
oh yeah just come check me out
yeah i love it and i mean there's a real
synergy here too because of course we
want to help you build your youtube
channel make some money but it's not
just how much money you make it's also
how much money you keep how much money
you invest and i love following anthony
myself uh always just keeping me on the
straight and narrow too because at any
level you can still blow up your life at
any level you can still blow up your
finances it's really not how much money
is coming in because if you're spending
more than you make uh then you can still
get into trouble really fast really
money management is huge it is it is i
tell them the number one thing to wealth
is margin
this is it's just margin you know it's
if you have five thousand dollars coming
in
and your bills are at five thousand you
can't build wealth um a lot of people
think you have to make a hundred
thousand dollars a million dollars a
year to build wealth we know when
studies are showing that really you know
you have accountants school teachers
police officers um who are making
anywhere between 50 000 to 70 80 000 a
year those are the ones who are becoming
millionaires why because they've created
margin they live below their means
they're investing into you know the
proper things like your 401ks your roth
401ks your uh you know your iras paying
off their homes avoiding debt living
below their means and those are the ones
think about it they're making let's say
60 000 a year on average but they're
investing right so when they retire they
get a pay raise what do you mean anthony
well it's simple if they're retiring
with 1.5 million dollars and they're
living off of the interest of that which
is going to be about 10 000 a month she
went or he went from making sixty
thousand dollars a year to now living
off of the the interest of ten percent
that's a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars a year
that's twenty thousand dollars a month
no that's ten thousand dollars a month
so um man yeah uh come check out the
channel because we're we're teaching the
the the pre the practical steps um and
really on how you can start this journey
and you're right sean it's not about how
much money you make your income is
important but the number two thing
behind that is your margin what are you
doing to live below your means
yeah and you can of course check out
links to anthony's stuff in the uh
youtube stream of this
um as well as the clickable channel name
in the title of the youtube video if
you're watching on facebook of course
you can head over to
anthonyokneel.com i want to land the
plane on one more question that uh
especially from someone spirals kinks
and coils says
from someone like anthony who has a book
also has a youtube channel you're
building out other products and programs
you'd be building up different pieces
and i love this question because it says
there's a void that i want to fill but
do you recommend starting with videos on
youtube or a book or both and so we're
talking about personal branding and when
you look at someone like you who has
like in a way all the things you got the
studio and the momentum and the podcast
and the youtube channel and the books
and and and you're continuing to do more
as you're further on your journey let's
go back to the beginning what do you say
someone should do first
when they know the direction they want
to go should they write the book first
youtube channel first what do they do
first oh man i'm gonna say simple get
your message
build your community build once you
build a community
create products and services that
impacts that community
um and i think you don't want to go
write a book and you don't have a
community to sell the book to and so
that is one thing that that i'm focused
on for the rest of this year is i want
to build my community uh a lot more you
know i have 300 plus on the youtube
channel i have close to 300 000
downloads on the podcast 200 000 on that
i'm trying to get my overall community
to 2 million by the end of this year
right between emails facebook and all
that type of stuff so this way when i
come out with my next book you know i
think a lot of people don't understand i
really want you to think about this you
guys
trust me if you build a community you
only need a good solid 2 000 people who
are willing to spend
497 on you within that year
that's it whether that's on the course
at 200 and that's 20 in a book or you
add it up think about it you only really
need 2 000 faithful people within your
community
that on average will spend about 497
dollars on you that's 1 million dollars
and so if you really focus on just just
building
as as much content
that is changing people's lives
your community will then grow
when your community grows so will your
currency and then your currency will
then grow because now you're creating
products and services that's feeding now
your community
and watch this as you feed your
community the number one marketing tool
in the world is not google adsense it's
not getting on facebook and paying ads
it's your community now your community
is going to say yo you need to check out
sean you need to check out anthony you
need to check out such and then now as
you're growing now your income will grow
so it all goes back to number one
don't don't do not chase the money and
really i'll be honest with you and sean
correct me if i'm wrong you know i've
written two books and those books have
not paid me as much money as my courses
and as youtube i think in my opinion
books as another layer of just something
i can offer my tribe
but writing books it's a lot of work
and it's not something that i wake up
saying oh i want to go write another
book today i'm like do i really have to
write another book
but
you know there is a layer to that that
adds to your your brand it adds to your
name it adds to your resume and i will
write another book probably uh the end
of next year but at the end of the day
i'm focused on youtube podcasts um and
courses and so the rest of this year all
i'm doing is saying hey you know what
mike told my team we're going to really
maximize youtube and podcast right now
that's our number one thing we're going
to be we're going to start on our second
course um
towards the end of this year then we'll
launch it next year once we launch that
we're serving the community then we'll
start the book but right now i make way
more money serving you all on youtube
and then also creating courses i mean
you can create a course and if you do it
right and it's impactful the course
actually has some meat to it it's
changing people's lives you guys listen
do the math you can make a million
dollars just from 2 000 people taking
your course at 497
so if i was you
i'm serving i'm i'm focusing on how do i
build something that is so impactful
that is changing so many lives how do i
build a community uh that is just stuck
with me because they know everything
that i push out everything that i that i
say is is for them
it will work but here's the thing and
i'll be quiet because i'm a preacher at
heart so i can talk all day long
everything starts with your character
and so if your character is is funny if
your character is i just want the money
please believe
the people in your community will know
that so make sure before you do anything
before you build any community make sure
you build your character make sure
you're making sure you're a young man a
young woman of integrity young men and
young women of character
and then watch everything impact and
grow from there put the book on pause
build your community
man that was a whole uh just spitting
fire at the entire end there and i love
this idea and anthony that's one of the
reasons why i love you so much is your
world class and your advice you've
brought excellence i mean just look at
your studio look at the details of of
your business your brand uh but but we
have that similar value and similar
ethic that really the foundation of
building a strong personal brand that
it's building your character
first
man you just got me fired up with that
and uh i'm so grateful if you happen to
just be joining on today uh this stream
definitely catch the replay uh so many
gems were dropped anthony dropped three
specific tips he broke down just the
best really business model when it comes
to building a personal brand online
there uh we we learned a little bit
about a studio and so check all of that
out and if you want to learn from
anthony as well so many other great
speakers
growwithvideolive.com
is coming up in just a week if you want
five percent off tickets tickets are
almost sold out use the promo code gwvl
show when checking out we got gary
vaynerchuk it's pretty crazy but we
really dialed in to run a show we got
alex and layla hermosie patrick bet
david ryan pineda brett knutson vanessa
lau heather torres anthony o'neil
jasmine star the row show live chalene
johnson pat flynn omar l to corey benji
travis aaron on demand and so many more
and so if you want to check out the
entire lineup um that's all i grow with
videolive.com
and you can check out links in the
description down below anthony thank you
so much for joining us today
on the grow with video live show
thank you man it's such an honor
this thing
is your gateway to get out of the thing
that you complain about but people would
rather complain about how it is than put
in the work we need to start
understanding how big this opportunity
is because for everybody in this room
you will sit back in 20 30 years and
regret if you didn't execute in this era
it has never been a better time in the
human race ever to actually just go all
in on you
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time to be
here
this is the greatest golden era of not
only business but life
i desperately want you to win
but this is on you